Serge Klarsfeld à la case profession du
père vous ne manquiez jamais de répondre
mort en déportation que diriez-vous en
ce qui vous concerne
vous direz combattant pour la vérité
historique vous avez effectivement dédié
votre vie à la traque des anciens nazis
tout cela s'est-il fait précisément au
nom du père de ce père qui a été arrêté
par la Gestapo et qui en se livrant vous
avez parié
non c'est pas pour mon père seulement
c'est pour
toutes les victimes mon père était l'une
des victimes
mais la nuit où on arrêtait mon père
j'entendais les les enfants de nos
voisins criez parce qu'ils étaient
battus par la Gestapo pour faire avouer
où était caché leur frère aînés donc
c'était j'ai toujours senti que c'était
collectif diriez-vous que ce 30
septembre 1943 a été le fondement de
votre vie d'homme et de ce combat
c'est le moment référence de ma vie
parce que
notre père nous avait dit à ma sœur moi
et à ma mère
quelques jours avant la rafle
si on est arrêté moi je survivrai parce
que je suis fort mais vous vous ne
survivrai pas et donc écoute suivez les
instructions et nous étions très
turbulents mais dans la cachette qu'il
avait construit derrière le double fond
d'un placard
nous avons été très
silencieux nous savions que d'un moment
à l'autre nous allions mourir ou si nous
étions pris bien entendu c'était pas
d'un moment à l'autre mais pour nous en
tant qu'enfant on savait qu'on allait
mourir votre vocation de combattant de
la rivalité historique et vraiment née
par un matin glacial d'hiver au camp de
berkanao dans un face à face terrible
avec les morts oui parce que
j'étais très insouciant insouciant même
de l'avenir au point de vue
professionnel bon je voulais être
heureux c'est tout et puis
je me suis marié avec une Allemande qui
n'était pas juive on était heureux mais
au moment d'avoir un fils
j'ai décidé de renouer avec mon père ou
Dieu pas de renouer puisque il
m'arrivait de rêver de lui etc mais de
reconstituer la dernière étape de son
calvaire et je suis allé au Mémorial de
la Shoah qui ne portait pas le même nom
à l'époque
j'ai décidé d'aller à Auschwitz c'était
la guerre froide
personne allait de l'Ouest à Auschwitz
je suis allé au Schmitt à Auschwitz même
au camp le camp qui est le camp
principal il y avait quand même beaucoup
de monde des Polonais des checks etc et
à bien que nous le camp des Juifs il n'y
avait personne j'étais tout seul dans un
immense camp et j'ai compris que j'étais
en quelque sorte arrivé mon moi aussi
par miracle
par le sacrifice de mon père j'étais pas
arrivé là mais
j'entendais quand même
[Musique]
le cri de mon peuple et
donc j'ai réalisé que je faisais partie
d'une catégorie exceptionnelle de Juifs
qui avait vécu la pire menace contre
les Juifs dans l'histoire et en même
temps qui avait vu après 20 siècle la
renaissance
d'un État juif et donc que c'était
exceptionnel et que je devais donc et
défendre la mémoire des victimes et
défendre
la cause d'Israël la cause juive les
causes juives
votre épouse allemande protestante et la
fille d'un soldat de la Wehrmacht en
quoi cette rencontre a également été
déterminante dans ce combat elle était
déjà déterminant c'est-à-dire que si je
n'avais pas
je serai peut-être pas aller à Auschwitz
etc c'est c'est en quelque sorte une
synergie
franco-allemande
notre couple nous étions jeunes nous
étions plein d'énergie
et il est arrivé
un événement imprévu mais a été révoqué
de son poste à Paris et ça
personnellement je l'ai pas supporté
donc j'ai des béates dans sa campagne
contre
un chancelier allemand qui avait été un
dirigeant de la propagande hitlérienne
vers l'étranger pendant la guerre
et elle l'avait attaqué dans des
articles dans Combat le journal Combat
qui a disparu
et elle a été révoquée pour avoir écrit
à Paris des articles disant que c'est
mal pour l'Allemagne de cette donnée un
chancelier nazi alors que vilibrante lui
était résistant c'était le maire de
Berlin vers
tt berlinoise alors elle aimait
vivreonde et donc
tout naturellement en tant qu'amant
s'est battu contre King et donc j'ai
décidé de
qu'on allait s'engager voilà et comme
j'ai été à l'époque administrateur de
l'ORTF
et bien j'ai été compétent dans les
affaires de radio le chancelier avait
été
dirigeant de la propagande radiophonique
donc je comprenais les problèmes
d'organigramme etc et j'étais en mesure
de constituer un dossier
contre l'efficace
vous ne vous destiniez pas au départ au
barreaux cette profession a d'emblée
était un moyen jamais une fin j'ai été
militant et je me suis plongé dans la
l'action militante
à 35 ans mais complètement plongée et
j'ai démissionné mon travail et puis je
me suis dit un moment c'était d'ailleurs
en Amérique du Sud je me suis dit j'ai
lu le monde il y avait un petit entre
filets
disons que
ceux qui avaient l'équivalence de
sciences politiques du diplôme de
sciences politiques ce qui avait le
diplôme pouvait entrer en troisième
année de droit je me suis dit
comme j'envisageais de
poursuivre les complices français de des
dirigeants allemands de la solution
finale je me suis dit bon c'est une
profession qui me convient parce que je
ne sais rien faire donc je peux être
avocat
auriez-vous pu obtenir les mêmes
résultats sans collecter l'épreuve
démasquer les accusés monter des
dossiers et les défendre aux côtés des
participes autrement dit si vous n'aviez
pas été de A à Z à l'origine de ce
travail de titan un travail acharné non
il fallait à la fois être
historien voir quand même des notions de
droit et vraiment c'était une passion et
en même temps c'était une terre il n'est
presque inexplorée parce que les
archives officiels étaient fermés
et mon rôle a été déterminant parce que
j'ai su ouvrir les archives officiels et
avoir accès aux documents et pouvoir
écrire l'histoire de la solution finale
en France et
chaque dossier était très bien constitué
mais je l'ai constitué en tant
qu'historien et un peu en tant qu'avocat
vous savez pour être avocat il suffit
d'être intelligent et puis bon
travailler un peu mais j'étais pas
spécialisé
le crime contre l'humanité c'était pas
une une branche du droit à l'époque et
donc vous étiez un avocat particulier
parce qu'il vous est arrivé
un certain nombre de reprises de flirter
avec l'inégalité pour mener les
bourreaudières devant un tribunal la fin
justifie-t-elle tous les moyens pour que
la justice soit faite oui vous réussir
dans notre dans notre action nous étions
faibles très faible donc il faut une
action radicale et énergie que il
fallait agir illégalement
assumer l'illégalité et montrer que le
véritable scandale était l'impunité des
criminels et pas
les égalité relativement légère que
que nous nous permettions de faire et en
même temps de dire voilà notre notre
stratégie et lorsque j'ai été par
exemple condamné à la prison en
Allemagne j'ai dit et qu'on m'a dit on
vous donne le sursis j'ai dit je
recommencerai dès que je peux je
recommencerai et l'opinion publique peut
à peu compris qu'elle était notre
stratégie et y compris également que
l'illégalité pouvait aller jusqu'au bout
si la société politique allemande
refusait de juger les principaux
criminels Serge korsel vous avez
également poursuivi jusqu'en Bolivie
Klaus Barbie surnommé le boucher de Lyon
c'est vous qui avez retrouvé le télex de
Barbie ordonnant la déportation de 44
enfants des yeux une pièce déterrée
parmi des millions d'autres archives
finalement cette trouvaille relève du
miracle
oui mais
moi je ne suis pas allé en Bolivie je
suis allé jusqu'à la frontière
bolivienne c'est béate qui est allé à
plusieurs reprises en Bolivie qui a été
arrêté là-bas etc c'était il y a plus de
50 ans
moi je suis allé pour essayer de monter
l'enlèvement de Barbie avec Régis Debré
et
heureusement que nous l'avons fait parce
que nous l'avons fait avec un
ami bolivien de l'opposition un ancien
haut fonctionnaire bolivien et
10 ans après notre tentative
infructueuse
cet habit bolivien est devenu ministre
de la sécurité en Bolivie c'est lui qui
a arrêté Barbie c'est lui qui l'a mis
dans l'avion
c'est vous qui avez trouvé cette pièce
de documents
je cherchais j'avais le feu vert
d'ailleurs de François Mitterrand qui
était Président de la République pour
retrouver dans les archives ce document
et ça m'a beaucoup servi le feu vert
parce que
cela m'a ouvert les archives du
ministère de l'Intérieur
de l'époque de Vichy et j'ai pu donc
avoir accès à des documents qui
jusque-là
n'avait plus il n'a pas vu pu voir et le
tel existe je finis par le retrouver
dans la cave du centre de documentation
juive contemporaine
et c'était un document tout à fait
essentiel c'est grâce à ce document que
Klaus Barbie a été extradé où vous
diriez aussi que c'est la sa
médiatisation
il n'a pas été extradé d'abord il a été
expulsé c'est une comment dire une une
solution que nous avions trouvé
qui n'était pas l'extradition
l'expulsion notre ministre de la
Sécurité bolivien lui a fait ôter ça
nationalité bolivienne pour avoir menti
quand il était entré en Bolivie et donc
il a été expulsé par extradé et cette
pièce c'était nécessaire pour le grand
public le télex des yeux mais elle
n'était pas nécessaire pour pour les
jurés parce que les copies authentifiées
avaient été
avaient été présenté
et il y avait une copie à Washington que
je m'étais procurée une copie à la Cour
internationale de justice de La Haye et
une copie à Nuremberg donc j'étais
tranquille quand même même si je n'avais
pas retrouvé
le télex original
c'est aussi grâce à votre obstination
que Bousquet le guetouvier et Papon ont
été poursuivis
ation celle de mon fils parce que c'est
mon fils qui a été l'avocat dans
l'affaire Papon et dans l'affaire
Touvier
moi j'ai été avocat dans l'affaire
Bousquet le gué mais je ne me suis pas
présenté au procès Papon ni aux pensées
tout vieux je suis jamais entré dans la
salle d'audience et Bousquet le gué ça
s'est terminé par la mort naturelle de
legué qui a été le premier inculpé pour
créer une contre l'humanité en France et
par la mort brutale l'assassinat de de
Bousquet par un déséquilibré mais je
n'en ai pas été flashé alors justement
qu'il s'agisse du procès d'un vieillard
Maurice Papon de la chaise vide de Loïs
Brunner ou des procès impossibles de
tout vie et le gay décédé vous l'avez
dit avant que la justice ne soit rendue
à vos yeux tous ses procès se valent
non les affaires toutes ces affaires on
montrait parce qu'elles ont eu un grand
retentissement des milliers de messages
par la presse écrite radio télé sont
arrivés aux Français peu à peu la vérité
historique
c'est imposé
le rôle
néfaste de Vichy dans ce domaine a été
véritablement mise en lumière voilà
est-ce qu'il y a une plus grande
responsabilité à défendre la mémoire des
morts êtes-vous au fond Serge karsfeld
leur dernier parent ou leur dernier
rempart contre l'oubli non il y en aura
d'autres tous les historiens qui
travaillent dans dans le bon sens en
recherchant la vérité le
chercheur qui travaille aux archives
départementales sur ce qui s'est passé
dans sa petite ville et bien il en fait
autant que moi il va dans la même
direction non j'ai aucune inquiétude
pour l'avenir de notre mémoire il y a
maintenant des millions de documents sur
la Shoah ils sauront tous dans des
centres documentation
comme il y a de Vachem comme Washington
comme le Mémorial de la Shoah à Paris
donc j'ai aucune inquiétude pour
l'avenir de la mémoire c'est un domaine
qui interpelle
comment un peuple qui était le peuple le
plus avancé on peut dire au point de vue
société
au monde a pu
tenter de mettre à mort un peuple qui
est peut-être un des plus anciens encore
en existence aujourd'hui donc
vous n'avez pas d'inquiétude pour
l'avenir de la mémoire et pourtant de
plus en plus de professeurs de collèges
et de lycées se plaignent de ne pas
pouvoir enseigner ou aborder la question
de la Shoah en classe certains en ont
même peur
oui ça ne se passe pas particulièrement
à Paris ça se passe dans dans des
périphéries là où il y a des des
jeunes maghrébins dont la mémoire est
altérée et qui voudrait que leur mémoire
soit
reconnue la mémoire des massacres qui
ont été commis pendant la colonisation
il faut trouver des solutions mais il
faut que les professeurs soient formés
c'est le rôle du Mémorial de la Shoah et
ça avance mais c'est très long
l'éducation et il y a toujours des
soubresauts politiques qui font que rien
n'est jamais parfait mais je peux dire
quand je me reporte à la période où moi
j'étais
tout jeune au lycéen ét les progrès ce
qui nous concerne notre mémoire ont été
extrêmement important il n'empêche que
du point de vue politique
l'un ne va pas avec l'autre quand nous
avons commencé notre action la droite
extrême était
toute petite aujourd'hui électoralement
elle est très importante alors justement
l'antisémitisme est une maladie qui mute
et se perpétue particulièrement en temps
de crise il touche vous le disiez une
partie des jeunes de banlieue où les
clichés les plus éculés prospère comment
faire échec à ce que les sociologues
nomment la concurrence des mémoires la
concurrence des victimes il faut que les
problèmes politiques soient résolus
si la question palestinienne était
résolue il y aurait beaucoup moins de
problèmes
mais
je suis pas là pour résoudre les
problèmes politiques je suis incapable
de les résoudre c'est à ceux qui
dirigent les États
les entités politiques de de les
résoudre
vous avancez une piste il faut relier la
Shoah à l'aspect meurtrier de la
colonisation à la question de la
supériorité des races moi j'ai pas
beaucoup de problèmes effectivement
lorsque je rencontre des des gens qui
sont originaires de l'Afrique noire ou
de Dieu du Maghreb
je leur dis que le sort des Juifs les
Juifs étaient à peu près comme eux dans
opprimé pendant très longtemps et que
c'est à eux de trouver les moyens mais
il faut pas qu'ils oublient qu'ils sont
français et que les Juifs en France
malgré les persécutions qu'ils ont subi
dans cette période de 40-44 et bien son
patriote et et il ne se désolidarise pas
de la France bon il faut il faut raisons
garder il faut avoir du bon sens mais
c'est très très difficile quand les
passions prennent le pas sur la raison
justement un mot sur la reconnaissance
en 1995 de la responsabilité de l'État
français dans la déportation et
l'extermination des Juifs est-ce que ça
a été le point culminant de votre
domicile de combat ou juste un jalon
c'était un tournant mais c'était pas la
reconnaissance de la responsabilité de
l'État français sa Mitterrand l'avait
reconnu c'était la responsabilité de la
France c'est-à-dire que pour Jacques
Chirac et j'en sais quelque chose parce
que j'en ai parlé beaucoup avec lui
avant et bien il y avait une guerre
civile entre deux France la France de
Gaulle et de la Résistance intérieure et
la France de
Philippe Pétain et Pierre Laval et ces
symptomatiques au mois de juin 42 il y a
eu Bir-Hakeim et au mois de juillet 42
il y a eu la rafle du veldive c'était
une guerre civile et
la France est
responsable aussi bien de ce qui a été
fait en positif qu'en négatif et c'est
ce que
Jacques Chirac a reconnu dans sa phrase
ce jour-là le jour de Rave du valdive la
France accomplissait les réparable
et ça c'est un point très important
cette reconnaissance là c'est un point
très important parce que de là il en a
tiré les conséquences et les deux
gouvernements qui ont suivi celui de
Lionel Jospin et de d'Alain Juppé ont
créé la Fondation pour la mémoire de la
Shoah ont accordé une pension aux
orphelins de la déportation et ont créé
une commission pour indemniser les
victimes des des discriminations
matérielles on veut dire
contre la réédition de certains textes
de Céline c'est enflé antisémite assorti
d'un appareil aucune valeur d'après vous
si
j'ai pas dit que malheureusement les
textes de Céline ont eu une importance
sur beaucoup de Français qui ont
collaboré et sur l'antisémitisme en
général parce qu'ils ont un certain
talent aussi
mais pour une édition critique
[Musique]
faite par un historien comme
Pierre-André taghef qui connaît
parfaitement le sujet qui peut démonter
toutes les sources et toutes les
ressorts de de l'antisémitisme de Céline
d'ailleurs j'ai
garantie on peut dire moralement ou du
point de vue de la morale politique en
tout cas
l'apparition par les éditions fayardes
Mein Kampf
donc vous n'êtes pas fait donc en fait
donc Serge Cassel vous n'êtes pas contre
la réédition de ces textes assortis d'un
appareil critique à sortir de l'appareil
critique fait une fait par un historien
comme Pierre-André Taguieff qui va dans
le bon sens et qui est prêt à élucider
disons le comportement de
Céline votre confrère Henri Leclerc ne
croit pas au monstre pourriez-vous comme
lui dire que le pire criminel est un
être humain comme un autre que c'est un
frère
il était un frère si je regarde la photo
de Reichmann dit à 12 ans et moi 12 ans
nous sommes pareils mais
à un moment
il a choisi le mal
et d'autres choisissent le bien voilà
donc
à partir du moment où il a choisi le mal
il devient un monstre par ses actions
mais il n'est pas un monstre dans la vie
courante ça peut être un bon père ça
peut être
il peut comment dire apporter quelque
chose à l'humanité en tant que
technicien ou médecin etc
mais à partir du moment où il a choisi
le mal
il porte ce mal sur les épaules il a
pris cette responsabilité il aurait pu
ne pas le prendre je le dis pour les
gens qui ont un libre arbitre parce que
les gens qui sont au bas de la société
qui n'ont pas eu la chance d'étudier etc
n'a pas qu'ils n'ont pas eu la chance
d'être heureux dans leur enfance etc bon
on des circonstances atténuantes pas
ceux qui ont eu une excellente éducation
et qui ont eu les moyens de résister à
la trait du mal ou à la fascination du
mal
sache qu'un seul vous avez contribué à
transformer l'Allemagne vous avez œuvré
à la réconciliation franco-allemande
vous avez permis à la mémoire de se
perpétuer en conservant des preuves
incontestables de l'horreur vous avez
exigé et obtenu réparation vous le
disiez même si aucune vie perdu notre
prix que vous reste-t-il à faire
aujourd'hui
mourir le plus heureusement possible
[Musique]
merci
à vous